There's plenty of Game of Thrones trivia to
be found online — a show this epic is sure
to have its behind-the-scenes surprises and
Easter Eggs galore.
But die-hard fans are probably sick of hearing
the same old bits.
So rejoice, supernerds!
Here are a few nuggets out of Westeros even
the show's biggest fans may not have heard
yet …
“Oh my god.”
“Oh my god!”
“Wow.”
“You have your very own Game of Thrones
iron throne toilet!”
Okay — maybe that guy knows all this.
But do you?
Watch the throne
In the books, the Iron Throne itself is epic
— it's made of a thousand swords and has
actual stairs you have to climb to reach the
seat.
The show's producers decided to go with something
more realistic, but the show's prop-throne
does hide some pretty epic Easter Eggs for
the super fans ....
“When you play the game of thrones, you
win, or you die.”
As some obsessed Redditors first pointed out
and IGN reported, if you look closely at the
throne, you should spot a copy of Gandalf's
sword from the Lord of the Rings, as well
as swords from Robin Hood: Prince of Thieves
and Kingdom of Heaven.
Heart of gross
In one of the most memorable scenes from Season
1, Daenerys chowed down on a stallion heart
to win the approval of the Dothraki bigwigs.
Actress Emilia Clarke wasn't faking her disgust
— the "horse heart" she was eating was actually
made of a gummy bear-like substance that had
been injected with a red sugary syrup so "blood"
would realistically burst out of the heart
and flow down her face as she ate.
But just because something is sweet doesn't
mean it's palatable: Clarke says she spent
much of the day "heaving into a bucket."
King confusion
On the show, the "Night King" is the imposing
leader of the White Walkers.
In the books, there is a character named the
"Night's King," but he's a legendarily cruel
human figure — not a White Walker.
“Thirteen years, he and his queen ruled
over his brothers, making sacrifices as black
as their cloaks.”
In the books, these freezer-burned freaks,
in fact, do not appear to have any noticeable
social structure or hierarchy at all, let
alone a king, making his icy highness a TV
exclusive.
Slice and dice
Game of Thrones is a television sensation
around the world, but we're not all necessarily
watching the same thing.
When China's state TV station began re-airing
the series in 2014, fans quickly noticed that
they had heavily censored the episodes — cutting
nearly all of the violence and nudity.
That's a bit like cutting all of the "Roadrunner
chasing" out of a Wile E. Coyote cartoon.
But it could be worse: In Turkey, the government
outright banned the show in 2014 from being
played at the country's military training
schools, citing a desire to protect recruits
from viewing images of "sexual exploitation,
pornography, exhibitionism, abuse, harassment
and all negative behaviors."
Wandering minstrels
Quite a few musicians have had cameos on the
show through the years, including Snow Patrol
singer Gary Lightbody, making a vocal contribution
…
"She kicked and wailed / A maid so fair / But
he licked the honey from her hair.”
… Coldplay drummer Will Champion doing his
thing at the infamous Red Wedding, and Icelandic
post-rock group Sigur Ros playing minstrels
at Joffrey's wedding …
"Very good, very good.
Off you go."
Three members of the metal group Mastodon
also made an appearance during the battle
at Hardhome, and frontman Brent Hinds is set
to make a reappearance in season seven in
the same role.
Singer/songwriter Ed Sheeran will also make
a season seven cameo, orchestrated as a surprise
for his fan, Maisie Williams, also known as
Arya Stark.
Stunt butt
Many Jon Snow fans may have swooned when they
got a glimpse of his bare bottom during that
Season 3 cave scene with Ygritte.
Unfortunately, that wasn't the real deal.
Shortly before filming for the season began,
actor Kit Harington says he fell from his
second-story window ledge in a drunken attempt
to retrieve his keys from his locked flat,
breaking an ankle, which left him unable to
film full-body shots for the first few weeks.
Luckily, a similarly-built crew member stepped
in to lend a butt.
So now you know: We were butt-boozled.
"Stop that.
You're making me uncomfortable."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!